today we're talking about sustainability
developer agility and client-side
encryption i'm kelsey and welcome to
this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news
governments play a vital role in
understanding and responding to climate
change but they lack the actionable
insights they need to respond quickly to
help bridge this gap google cloud is
introducing new offerings that help
organizations utilize earth observation
data to understand climate risks and
provide insights for policies
with these data-driven insights public
sector agencies and researchers can
improve their response time to climate
disasters make more accurate predictions
and implement disaster response plans
with greater confidence
these offerings climate insights for
natural resources and climate insights
for infrastructure are already having an
impact in the public sector and you can
read more about them and their use cases
on the blog google workspace gives you
real-time visibility into project
progress and decisions to help you ship
quality code fast and stay connected
with your stakeholders all without
switching tools and tabs
google workspace is also an open
platform and we're constantly expanding
our ecosystem in improving customization
options giving you the power to push
your software development even further
head to the blog to learn more about how
you can make software development more
agile speed up testing proactively
monitor and improve service reliability
government agencies regularly work with
sensitive data such as financial data
personally identifiable information or
proprietary information
handling this data requires agencies to
meet confidentiality and compliance
requirements
at the same time agencies don't want to
compromise on the collaboration
experience they provide to their
employees
google workspace already uses the latest
encryption standards to encrypt all data
at rest and in transit between our
facilities and with client-side
encryption google workspace is letting
agencies retain complete confidentiality
and control over their data by choosing
how and where their encryption keys are
stored
learn more about this and how it works
on the blog if you want to read more
about these announcements or see a full
list check out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you